10 tips that we need to know and tip
number one is start before you're ready
rad you talked about the importance of
starting now and you said you wish you
gave YouTube attention early on
um what do you wish you know everyone
watching this would know when it comes
to starting before you're ready
the incredible opportunity that YouTube
is it's uh and social media in general
but for us I mean we're on all the the
major platforms we're on Instagram and
Tick Tock and Facebook and uh LinkedIn
and Twitter but YouTube is by far the
biggest generator of leads and business
for our business by a country mile we've
got more subscribers on YouTube we just
ticked over 55 000 subscribers so that's
um more than all of our other channels
and it when we've interviewed our best
clients people that have been with us
for the longest they all found us on
YouTube all of them and because YouTube
is Evergreen content like our our best
performing videos kind of make me almost
cringe now because we filmed them like
six or seven years ago and they've had
hundreds of thousands of views our best
performing videos creeping up towards a
million views and the I just didn't
understand the the the opportunity that
we had and that everybody has with
YouTube I really didn't I saw it as like
a hint like something that got in the
way of what we had to do and it was
always like okay we've got to film some
content and I'd run out once a week for
an hour and just try to rush some
content out and so if I knew what I know
now now my entire job like my priority
with my business is to create the best
content possible and I wish I knew back
then now how valuable that would be for
our business I really do
that's powerful and uh Lloyd I'm curious
from you one of the things when it comes
to like start before you're ready is I
know for me personally there's a lot of
mindsets just that we roll in our mind
overthinking sometimes think about what
are people gonna think and um all this
stuff did you experience any resistance
when you thought about originally
putting yourself out there on camera or
what was some of the stuff when it comes
to you wanting to start
um but maybe some resistance you faced
yeah you know I felt that I probably
needed more experience or better
equipment or back then I wasn't a public
speaker I never had felt comfortable in
front of a camera or talking to people
even growing up when I was in high
school and in college I was the type of
student that if the teacher wanted a
volunteer or asked a question I would be
putting my head down making sure that we
didn't have any eye contact because I
was just that type of person so
um there were a lot of things holding me
back but at the end of the day I I
almost made it a challenge for myself to
just start recording and what's funny is
that I I mean I was really bad in the
beginning you can go back to my videos
2015 I'm like talking really fast
running out of breath and I remember
people leaving me comments calling those
things out and it would bug me because
I'm over here trying to create content
and people are seeing the flaws in me
but that didn't stop me I knew that you
know there was a bigger goal in mind I
wanted to create a brand for myself
awareness I'm in an industry tree where
there's hundreds of thousands of Agents
so I knew that video was going to help
me separate myself from everyone else so
it was just staying focused on that and
knowing that over time I was going to
get better I was not perfect from the
start and that's just pretty much the
route that I took and I knew that I had
to be consistent and just you know
forget how I feel or what I think people
might think of me I just need to do this
so powerful and rad you you hit on
something where a lot of us can feel
like we have a fear of not being an
expert and you actually kind of
mentioned like like you don't really
have to be an expert you can people can
learn from you where you are right now
break that down a little bit
100 uh in in the fitness industry I
think one of the one of the biggest
fears that I had was I I've always had
coaches and I always search for a new
coach and so I'm always working with
somebody that's better than me and the
people that work with me are obviously
working with me because I'm better than
them and I have something to offer them
and it took me a really long time to get
over that because I was always comparing
myself to people that I was learning
from and thinking well I'm not nearly as
good as as they are but always
benchmarking that off um you know
Fitness and calisthenics and the things
that I was doing and I thought well how
how can I really be somebody that's
trying to help other people when there's
people out there that are so much better
than me but the truth is something I've
learned over my Decades of being a coach
now is that my opinion the best coaches
are the people that are just a little
bit ahead of where you are in your
journey now I've worked with coaches
that are way ahead of me that are like
20 years Beyond me and they're less
connect to where you are in your journey
now and so there's always going to be
people who see you as somebody more
valuable than the guru there really is
and that's something that I've that
since I've you know punched that fear in
the face and and gone with it it's uh
it's given me a lot of confidence and
I've seen a lot more growth from it and
we get a lot of really good Praise on
our Channel I get a lot of comments
daily from people saying that they think
that this is one of the best fitness
channels and we're highly underrated and
X Y and Z and so your perception of
yourself and where you sit versus other
experts is not the reality of what your
audience sees you as
such a powerful and encouraging point
which brings us to number two which is
you don't need the best camera so uh
lloyda you mentioned this that sometimes
you had the fanciest camera or once you
got better stuff with amazing editing it
didn't mean that it would necessarily
get better views or more views than not
having as fancy of camera what what has
been your experience with this yeah so
when I started my channel I was filming
every single video for the first two
years using my iPhone and back then it
was an iPhone 6. that's all I had
um I was starting YouTube I knew that
cameras could get pricey the one that I
was looking at back then it was like
around 700 and I said you know what once
I know I'm 100 committed to creating
content and I start making some money
from AdSense then I'm gonna take that
money and invest it and purchase a
camera so what's crazy is that you guys
can go to my channel and you can see the
older videos that I have which I film
with this iPhone the quality is not even
the best they have hundreds of of
thousands of views and more recent
videos that I filmed with like a 4k
camera you know they're not getting as
many views so at the end of the day it's
not really so much the the camera or the
equipment is whether or not you're
creating content that people are
searching for that they actually want to
learn about whether it's a skill or
whatever it is that they're looking for
and that's pretty much what has been my
experience yeah I love that tip and then
rad passing it back to you number three
is get clear on who your channel is for
and right before this it sounds like
recently you took that to a whole nother
level especially as a business owner
thinking about like kind of your target
audience Target customer uh but but
break this down on why this is one of
the things you wish you knew back when
you were starting YouTube yeah so we
were
you know we were making videos for for
everybody you know and and when I was
talking to the camera it was I had no
Clarity on who it was that I was talking
to and I would say things that I would
then would stop and we'd refilm it I
think I that that's not going to make
this person feel included or that's
going to exclude that person and the
truth is that the more laser focused you
get um you know if you're if you're not
for like if you talk to everyone you're
not for anyone and so nobody will
resonate with what you say and go wow
this person really gets me and and I
want to learn more from them you're just
too Mor you know you're too middle of
the road and so once we identified who
our audience was and and when you look
at our YouTube channel 85 of our viewers
are men and when you look at our
customers the people that are
subscribers of our app the vast majority
of men and and the vast majority are
actually between the age of 35 and 45
and so once we started to understand
that and we learned what people's
interests were it became so much easier
to create content because I wouldn't
question should I make this video or
shouldn't I it just completely removed a
whole bunch of ideas of no my audience
wouldn't want to know that and it made
me far more confident on the ideas that
on the big ideas of the videos that I
was going to make because I was like
yeah that is the kind of thing that this
person would would want to see and it's
funny because it's actually who I was 10
years ago who our best audience is you
know
that's a powerful tip that you mentioned
and if you're watching this
um in our challenge or
um in the replay
who were you five or ten years ago one
of the best YouTube channels you can
make is just serving the person you were
yesterday which is pretty good person to
Surf because you were that you can
empathize with that you could put
yourself into those shoes and then you
can share the learnings and lessons from
where you are now so that's so powerful
and we've been talking about how Clarity
is power and how getting really clear on
that let's head it over to number four
here and rad we're going to stay on you
uh number four is research before you
press record and you talked about the
importance of planning thoroughly
researching and preparing before you
press record and in just a second I'm
going to ask lloyda kind of her process
of coming up with content ideas but for
you what has been why is this such a big
deal man this is huge in all honesty
this is one of the biggest wins that
I've had in recent times I didn't used
to do this we we used to uh we'd sit
down and we'd go oh my God we've got to
film some videos today we don't have any
content for next week what are we going
to do uh let's do this and of course
that just really it's so hit and miss
it's kind of like throwing mud against a
wall and hoping that it will stick and
since I've really committed to VRA and
the seven the seven hours I I spend a
lot of time researching and so I have a
a Google doc and I have um my research
so I've got my big ideas I've got a tab
for the best the highest Search keywords
that are in my Niche that I can reflect
back to at any time so that I don't
always have to keep searching for what's
a high search keyword I can just go back
to that Tab and go oh that's right those
keywords are pretty pretty highly
searched for
um and I found that in the earlier
stages that I would use that a lot I
would use a lot of um you know what are
people searching for and what do I think
I can do well but the further I go along
the journey the ideas come to you more
easily because when you've got more
content out there you get more
engagement from people you get people
asking questions and you know you can
start using the asq strategy they ask
answer specific questions and so now the
research is one of the biggest things
that I do I'll spend a lot of time
researching something and the biggest
win for me lately is really coming up
with that big idea being really really
clear on okay what's the big idea of
this getting my title dialed in and I'm
spending a lot more time creating titles
now before I press record and then I'll
also coming up with the thumbnail if
it's a long form
and doing that makes it so much easier
to create content that's good and I've
really only committed like thoroughly
committed to that process probably in
the last month or so and I'm seeing
incredible growth from that my videos
are getting a lot more engagement so
yeah it's really cool I love that you
shared that and you know what's also
kind of cool about the VRA system is
after you've started with it and once
you get some momentum and once you get
some views and you get some subscribers
you mentioned it's you can always double
down on it but eventually a momentum
kicks in where there's kind of endless
content to make because your community
is giving you a feedback loop of what
content to make next and it's kind of
inexhaustible so research is so powerful
but eventually to your point of asq
really you just have your community kind
of doing the research for you and
vocalizing the themes for you you just
start going wow like a lot of people I
wouldn't have thought to make this video
but they're giving me that feedback so I
just want to encourage that you're
watching this when you're just starting
it's nice to have tools like answer the
public and some of the keyword research
tools we talk about to get you started
but eventually momentum picks up and so
lloyda I'm curious for you though
um even from where you have been but
even where you are today how are you
coming up with different video ideas and
what does uh you preparing for shooting
videos look like so it's kind of similar
to what dad was mentioning instead of
Google docs I love to use Trello so
anytime that I have an idea that comes
to my mind I put it on Trello I have
different cards for like a long form and
a short form just through all of the
videos that I have created in the past
looking at the comments the questions
that people are asking I use those also
as possible topics to create content I
do a lot of polls on my community tab on
YouTube on Instagram because what I have
noticed is that sometimes I come up with
these great video ideas and I think you
know these are great titles and then I
go ahead and create a video and it
doesn't really get a lot of views so I
want to make sure that I'm creating
content that people actually want to
watch that they're searching for the
comments that they leave the feedback
that I get that's kind of where I get a
lot of the the ideas of what I come up
with and just kind of similar to what
red was mentioning I'm now more
intentional first of thinking of the
title and the big big goal of that video
and then also how I can end it and where
I can direct people to either a playlist
or another video so that they stay
within my channel for a longer period of
time so strong and let's take it to
number five and this was our quick tip
of the day but we'll Circle back on it
number five is start your videos with a
strong hook and one of the lessons you
learned was starting with the hook
instead of a long intro or a short
trailer and so what is it that you've
learned about hooks
just like you were mentioning right
before we got started with all of this
you know I used to put the short trailer
with the music and the everything and
then when I you know did the program and
then you guys were like no you got to
get straight to the point I saw more
engagement on my videos people were
sticking longer obviously if they're
watching my videos they probably know
who I am so I don't have to say my name
again and it's just I don't know I like
it better because I'm just getting
straight to the point if you come to my
channel if you watch my videos there's
no fluff like you're getting straight
like all of the information that I'm
providing you so having that strong hook
coming up with it before you press
record it's really going to allow you to
have a better understanding of how you
want to do the video and again where you
want to direct them at the end whether
it's to another video that could be you
know attached to that one or a playlist
and that's something that I learned
through the program
um I was not doing that before but once
you guys mentioned you know at the end
send them to another video that can
relate to what you just talked about
I've been doing that and and yeah I've
noticed great results amazing that kind
of TAPS into our sixth point which was
end your videos with a CTA to another
video or playlist and I am curious uh
rad
um how you think about creating videos
maybe putting videos in series or
um how many videos you shoot at once and
then how you're ending your videos so
that's been a huge um development for me
recently from uh because I actually I
went through VRA over a long period of
time I would watch one or two lessons
and then I would Implement for a week or
two or three and then I'd go back and
watch more lessons I didn't just cram it
all in and I found that that was really
useful and one of the things that I've
been doing just recently is to create
video series and so rather than to make
one long video that uh might go for 20
minutes I'll turn that into three
shorter long form videos and I've even
done that with some shorts and I've had
some success I recently made a six video
series on how to do better pull-ups with
shorts and they did really well and you
know I was just testing out
um you know putting the one of six uh
two of six in with the title and so
that's been a big part of it and also
something else that I've done recently
which is a big change and it just makes
me cringe to think that I used to do
this because it makes so much sense I
used to do that well thanks for watching
I hope you got value out of that and if
you like And subscribe and I completely
don't do that anymore so an example
would be I just did a video on uh on
shoulder flexibility and this was a
follow-along routine and I I go through
the routine and without giving any hint
that the video is over I say so we're
working on shoulder flexibility here
you've got to make sure that you keep
working on hip flexibility and if you
click or tap and then immediately you
know my videos video video editors bring
up the end frame that has me on the side
pretty much exactly like the one that
you guys use and you know video here and
a video here sorry I'm trying to get
that right and then I'll have the video
that I'm referring to there and then
best for viewer
um there and uh yeah so that's an old
one
um that's really old it's about seven
years but any of my newer long form ones
you'd see it at the end
um and so that's uh that's been really
huge and just with hooks as well for me
what I found was I actually got rid of
the bumper in our videos because I
noticed that every single video where we
bought up a bumper bang retention went
off yeah so this is the video that I was
referring to and as it finishes I kind
of just go uh I'm saying you know you've
got to make sure you're doing this and
you've got to make sure you're doing
that but you'll see it in a sec when I
go and just click or tap the screen
there and there it is
um yeah I I got rid of my bumper
completely so we didn't have um bumpers
in videos anymore so I have a hook where
I tell my video editors that I want them
to put like 80 of their editing effort
into that first sort of 30 seconds and
then the rest of the video they don't
need to put as much effort in and no
bumper and we've got better retention so
sorry I know I jumped around a bit there
yeah that's great and so many powerful
tactics
um uh what has been your aha moment so
far
um if you're been consuming this number
one is start before you're ready number
two is you don't need the best camera
number three is get clear on who your
channel is for number four is research
before you press record number five it
starts your video with a strong hook
number six is end your videos with the
CTA to another video or to a video
playlist and then there's been a bunch
of Juicy nuggets just in the middle so
what's been one of your aho moments of
course smash the like and heart button
because people are still jumping on here
in our tube 1K challenge but we're gonna
keep it going with our special guests
and number seven is learn YouTube
optimization best practices and so
lloyda you mentioned a couple of these
whether it was the about section or
thumbnails and so what are some of the
things that you've learned whether in
VRA and just on your journey in general
that we can apply to our content yeah
you just mentioned the about section I
feel that that is something that a lot
of people neglect especially when
they're starting their YouTube channel
because something that I see a lot is
you know I go to someone's YouTube
channel I don't know who they are where
they're at what they do how can I get a
hold of them so really being specific
there on who your content is for also in
my descriptions before I would just do
like a one line now I have learned to be
more descriptive in my videos what the
video is about so that people know
exactly you know what the content
they're gonna get and all of that is
with tags I know that you guys have
mentioned you know we don't really have
to focus a lot on that but I have
learned to use vid IQ it's a really
helpful tool little things like that I
feel that have really taken my channel
to the next level from when I started
because when I started I wasn't doing
any of this you know I I wasn't putting
videos on playlists I wasn't naming my
playlist in a way that could possibly be
searchable and after I went through the
program I went back and I started to do
all of these little tweaks and I have
seen more engagement more retention and
more subscribers I love that and you
know one of the things we've been
talking about in this challenge is how
there's some new updates and one of the
new updates that YouTube has made that
we actually have to change as well is
the very first line of your about page
is now kind of like a tagline that
YouTube is putting right on our home
pages so you've got your name you've got
your at handle and then it tells you
your subscribers the amount of videos
and then it has like this first line
which is a whole new
opportunity to in about 50 characters or
less have again a tagline and we haven't
updated ours on think media because
we're assuming we have more
um time in the description so it says
thanks for checking out think media on
YouTube which is fine if that's
relational on the about page but it's
actually not updated for best practice
right here so we're going to be changing
that and that's kind of a new piece of
information for for being here in the
challenge just to think about not just
your about page but that first line of
your about page becomes kind of like the
one sentence that tries to summarize up
what your channel is about the value of
the audience is going to get and who
it's for rad is there anything you've
been doing in terms of how you optimize
title create playlists or things you do
on your channel
um that you've been doing lately we can
learn from yeah absolutely
um and this is actually a really new
development for me I've been listening
to a bunch of stuff from some content
creators and from you guys and I'm very
recently making a shift away from doing
titles that are keyword heavy to rather
shifting towards more doing titles that
relate to what a person would read and
that would entice them to click and it
is a relatively new experiment for me
but in early days I it seems to be
working better and it actually even is
driving the way that I'm creating my
content as well like it ties in with
that big idea when I come up with a
title that thinks that is targeted more
at what a person would read and be
enticed to click rather than what would
come up in the search algorithm then
that influences the big idea and it
absolutely influences the hook and I've
only been doing that for about two or
three weeks which means that the content
that I've been producing has only been
starting to get released this last week
and it's I've had some really really
good results in early days so that's um
that's a big one for me and and my
personal experience and my feelings from
you know watching some of the really big
YouTube creators that I look up to is
that that is something that is going to
produce better results than what I was
doing before yeah there's no doubt about
it and this is one of the reasons why we
update VRA is that really your content
should be keyword informed because it it
reveals intent and the topics
that your audience wants to learn about
however you really want to be writing
for humans not for robots right when it
comes to titles and in some cases
there's almost two different styles of
videos there's still the power of kind
of the keyword search based traditional
title and in some cases that might be
the best but in some cases it's
um not keyword based at all it doesn't
reveal anything it's going after kind of
mystery baits and uh you have that
opportunity like some of the stuff we've
been doing on on think media like why
going viral can hurt you or these
mistakes can kill 92 percent of YouTube
channels that's that's a different
approach than like how to write a
YouTube title both are good and learning
the skill set of both and you're
absolutely right you're really tapping
into more kind of a viral technique when
you go with some of those other styles
of time yeah and and I've been working
with the other style that you're
describing for while now and so I feel
like I'm good enough at that that I want
to try this other style of title and
you'll see it you'd see
um
I mean that example at the top there
there is an older style they're game
changing shoulder mobile like shoulder
Mobility exercises is a key word like
it's very very heavy but if you went to
my shorts you'd see some of them and
this is what I meant it's probably only
the five most recent I haven't even
looked at them yeah these are some of
those are are um uh some of the sort of
newer style of of titles that I've been
using but it's um yeah it's cool it's uh
it's it's pretty exciting and it gives
me gives me New Direction with what I'm
doing so I'm happy with that
I love it well number eight is one of my
favorite tips because I know we're busy
I know that getting it all done in every
season of life whether it's kids whether
it's business whether it's you go full
time on YouTube and then things get more
uh complex and you're building uh the
next stage out so number eight is get
more done in less time with batch
recording and so lloyda talk about as a
busy agent an investor and content
creator and you run events now and
you've had the evolution of your career
how has batch recording helped you and
describe for us not only what that is
but when it's batch recording day what'd
you do the night before what did you
what do you do that morning what's your
routine what do you eat for breakfast
and I'm kind of serious like what like
walk us through it like as you approach
a day where you create more than just
one video in one batch so when I first
started my YouTube Journey you know it
was kind of just picking up my phone I
had an idea let's film it obviously now
as I have gotten busier it's gotten to
the point that I really have been more
intentional about batch recording and
it's something that I wish I did back
then so what that looks like now is that
every two weeks I like to sit down and
write down a lot of different video
ideas that I have and kind of what I
want to be shooting
um in the next week or so I take a look
at the comments the the feedback that
I'm getting and the day for batch
recording that looks like almost five
hours of just recording in the morning I
get up the night before I'm taking a
look at exactly what I'm going to be
filming the next day
um I separate whatever clothes I'm gonna
wear I have like a five or six different
type of shirts that I can change out of
that way I'm wearing different stuff
depending on what I'm doing what I'm
eating for breakfast I like to eat
something healthy I don't want to be
heavy if I eat something that's too
heavy then I'm gonna feel like lethargic
and I want to just fall asleep after a
couple videos and then for the actual
day of shooting I make it very clear
with my videographer you know these are
the videos that we're going to record
we're just going to keep the the camera
rolling if I mess up I'm going to
continue we're not going to stop and
restart from the start and that's kind
of how that has been it has really
helped me it was definitely difficult
when I first started just because of how
I initially began back in 2015 but over
time I think that as you're a content
creator and if you really want to grow
this you have to learn to adapt and be
able to do these changes so that you're
more efficient and productive with your
time such uh well put answer and you've
really dialed in the system and I want
to encourage you
you know one of the things that you'll
see is that both rad and lloyda have
gone to a place where they got a
videographer now that's with them and
editors that are helping or people that
are are there but but batch recording is
something that is actually a huge key to
even getting to that place you know I
know for me what I would do is you know
I would the night before make sure my
batteries were charged and make sure
that I had my videos planned out usually
in a Google doc and then it would just
be scheduled on my calendar to set the
camera on a tripod and have a selfie
screen if I didn't have the selfie
screen I'd go back and forth back and
forth back and forth to test to make
sure the shot was right and then 30
minute record limit days and luckily
phones and new cameras don't have that
but there's all different levels you can
make this work with whatever you have
and I would try to shoot you know four
videos in one setting sitting so that I
could then release one video a week over
a month and only film potentially one
day a month and I want to remind you to
stick with us during the entire five
sessions of the challenge because we're
going to go into even more productivity
tips on session number five this is
session number three but session number
five we're going to go even deeper but
the next one is create multiple income
streams
um multiple streams of income and so rad
break this down you have got this great
Channel you mentioned there's been an
evolution of your business so maybe
there's been different seasons of this
you're definitely monetized so you kind
of have the YouTube side and you guys
have created an app which is software as
a service essentially and right and
you've got kind of that whole side so
kind of break down this idea of earning
money in what would be the Creator
economy yeah
um so I think the biggest thing for us
is that we when when we I'm a personal
trainer right so we didn't we learned
how to do content creation you know so
much of it from VRA and we started uh
when we started we were just hoping us
at creating videos but what happened was
that about 2018 2019 my brother and I we
realized that my brother's my business
partner that we had all our eggs in in
one basket of our gym and Yani said to
me what's going to happen if something
happens to our gym we need another
income stream and I said well what would
happen to our gym and he said I don't
know but what if it did and I'll never
forget it when he said that to me I
almost went white like a ghost in this
sick feeling in my stomach you know
because I was a new dad and I just I'd
never even considered that what happened
and so that was the point that we
decided to start creating online
programs and that was a pretty new thing
back in 2018 2019 there were Fitness
people that were doing it but it
certainly wasn't like what it's like now
and we had some very big success early
on we were fortunate enough that we were
able to leverage our YouTube channel and
then when covert hit in 2020 and the
world was forced to shut down
we had all this infrastructure in place
that was ready to just be sort of put
the foot down on the gas like we had our
cameras
um we had our studio in the gym we'd
already created a space for all of this
for for a podcast studio
um we had the the online programs that
were ready to be deployed and so it
wasn't like we were doing something new
it was just like okay well we have to
close the gym we're in lockdown let's
just amplify this and so we started
going live daily and doing live workouts
and we had massive growth during
um covert because of that on YouTube and
online and our online business started
to really take off and what happened
post covered where we were in in North
Sydney the small businesses in North
Sydney didn't recover from covert
because the big businesses they just
kept people working from home and so the
foot traffic that small businesses like
our gym and like cafes and like retail
stores that relied on
um so many of them closed down and so
for us we're we were able to just say
okay well this is more financially
viable for us to continue this online
business than it is to try to continue
the gym and if we didn't have that I
don't even know where we'd be now but it
wouldn't be in a good place and that's
just one example and then if you look at
you know YouTube monetization
um you know through YouTube ads and what
you can do with other platforms uh yeah
I think the idea of diversifying revenue
streams and looking at different
different ways that you can make money
that wouldn't be impacted where I mean
in our case when one was dramatically
impacted the other one just took off it
was it was life-changing for us
man such a powerful story and Lloyd I'm
curious when it comes to multiple
incomes streams we're talking about 10
things we wish we knew when we started
and when we asked you ahead of time you
said you kind of you would have become
an entrepreneur and as with the
entrepreneur thinking it would have been
kind of multiple income
um stream thinking and creating some
type of lead magnet Magnet or email list
so that's some rich topics break those
down of what you wish you would have
done differently and what we can do as
we're learning from you yeah so when I
first started I would have never in a
million years thought that creating
content would have led me to multiple
streams of income so for me I was just
kind of doing it as a hobby of recording
my journey as a real estate agent
putting it out there if someone learned
something valuable great if not it
wasn't a big deal to me and then over
time I started to generate business from
my YouTube videos I started to get
clients that were looking to either buy
or sell I started to get agents sending
me referrals and then that's when I
started to see you know this is really
powerful the fact that I have put myself
out there is helping me in my real
estate business over time as I was
getting questions and comments from
Agents as well in regards to what I was
talking about I saw that there was also
a need for training content for new real
estate agents so that led me to create a
new agent boot camp initially you know I
have no clue as to how to do funnels or
anything like that I have never even
been involved or researched at that
point I was I just told myself you know
what I need to create something because
clearly there's a need for it I did that
in 2020 and to my surprise I had 60
people sign up the first time then 100
then it kept on growing and then I said
you know what I'm on to something and
then along with that you know the
Affiliates so many different companies
that I was already using for my business
were reaching out I was signing up so
then that was another stream and then
over time as I have continued to grow
there have been Partnerships and
sponsorships
um five five figure type of sponsorships
that if it wasn't for me putting myself
out there I would have never got that
and even recently one of my favorite
companies that I use in my business
reached out to me about a week and a
half ago because they want me to be
their spokesperson for their company and
create content specifically for them so
I mean there's just so many different
things that have come about and that's
one of the things that I wish which I
knew in the beginning and going back to
creating a lead magnet I didn't have
something to
you know people that where people could
download or give me their email address
I wasn't collecting any of that if I was
I know that my email list would be so
much larger so if I did have you know an
event that I wanted to promote or a
training that I wanted to do I would
already have so many more people that I
could inform of that and it wasn't until
later on in in the years of me creating
content that I came up with something
but those are just some of the things
that I'm just really grateful that I
really stuck to this and if you're
watching this and you're like well I
don't know where to begin don't worry
I've been there and I figured it out wow
so encouraging and so many different
opportunities to make money in the
crater economy and they just continue to
increase we really get to almost like
Choose Your Own Adventure
um and kind of design the business that
we wanted to design learning new skills
as we go and so um after number 10 I
actually want to ask kind of a bonus
question I'm curious about your video
podcast that you've started we've had a
lot of people asking about that and you
have a Spanish channel so I I want to
touch on that and if you do have a
question we do want to land the plane
and honor our guest time but if there's
any point of clarity um put four
question marks before and after your
question uh but number 10 rad and here's
how you said it number 10 is commit to
the process and you said you really get
what you put in there's so much more to
YouTube success than just filming crap
and posting it so commit to learning
growing and putting in the work you know
explain maybe how what the way you used
to think and then how you think about
YouTube now when it comes to committing
to the process
yeah so as I said before the way that I
used to think about it it was always a
distraction it was a it was like an
afterthought it was like something that
like my brother used to say to me he'd
GO RAD we need some new content and I'd
go oh God all right here we go okay
let's go and film some content and we'd
go out and film it and and then he'd
take care of editing it and Publishing
and everything and it was always just
such a distraction for me I I just
didn't see the value of it and the you
know committing to the process now
it's um it's it for me it's just getting
better and better and better it's this
one percent better in every single video
and so I'm my process now is I'm
balancing putting out as much content as
I can with not putting out crap and
really trying to make sure that it's
really valuable and I'm fortunate that I
have a team of three video editors who
work full time for me and we have daily
meetings and I've been empowering them
lately to give me ideas and say what do
you guys think that we could do better
and they're coming at me with things
they've given me some really really good
ideas in fact one of them
um I'm my first ever Vlog which is about
a 10 or 11 minute video of a sort of a
day in my life
um is getting published this uh Monday
based on my video editor saying you know
rad you should do some content that's
more broader that goes to that isn't so
Niche to the fitness industry that maybe
people would relate to just because
you're a dad and because you work from
home and you run a business and and I
was quite afraid to do it but I did it
and I just gave them the footage and I'm
so impressed with what they came back
with I'm really excited to see how it
goes and so committing to the process
for me is it's just never ever settling
and it's and it's this idea that
um understanding that the the process is
like I have a goal and I have an end
goal and I have
um you know things that I want to
achieve but there's never a point that
that with the process of video creation
where I hit something and I go ah now I
can sit back I'm just always moving on
to the next thing and so my process now
is you know batch filming is huge for me
and what I find is I actually almost
have film weeks like I'll have a week
where I'll do a couple of days where
those are the the days that I'm filming
and then there'll be enough content for
my video editors to be editing for
several weeks and then I'll spend that
time just reviewing tweaking edits that
they've done and really just researching
researching coming up with better titles
getting really good ideas and then I'll
have a whole bunch of ideas and when I
come to my next filming week I'll have
to choose the ones that I'm going to do
you know because I've got so many ideas
and I'm like oh that one's going to be a
good one or that one's not going to be
so good and and so yeah it's it's it's
just this ongoing process and I'm only
really starting to see the benefits of
it I'm really starting to hit some
Milestones with growth and with views
and with engagement and
um yeah it's really cool